Writer/Director/Producer Joe Badon: When working
with 13 days and like $8,000, you are talking
about just a few hundred dollars a day that
you have for everything you’re doing.
And so you don’t have time to do pick-ups,
you don’t have time to set up a shot once
you get there.
You need to make sure you know exactly what
you’re going to be doing that day.
So when I go to finishing the script…I’m
an illustrator.
That’s what I did for a long, comic books
and children’s books and I did storyboards
for movies and I saw the importance of getting
the storyboards down so that when you get
to the set, you’re not wasting time.
I storyboarded the entire script from the
very first shot to the very last shot.
And I knew it was going to be important.
But I didn’t realize how important it was
until once we got there.
So my first AD Aria Mickenberg was able to
open up the book, look at the shot we needed
and say “We need this shot” and we go
“Okay, let’s set up the shot.”
Dan Waghorne our DP, sets the shot up, sets
the lights up, shoots it, we do a red circle
around that…
“What’s the next shot?”
Right here, right in front of us because we
have the storyboard illustrated.
And that was far and above a huge, important
piece of the puzzle to get the movie done
in time, on budget and finished without having
to go back and go “Oh…we totally forgot
this shot!”
Now we have to find the location again and
find the actors again and set up this time.
We didn’t have to do that because we looked
at the the storyboards and we had finished
it all.
Editor, Joseph Estrade: I didn’t expect
to walk into the first meeting of the film
and immediately know what the film was going
to look like in the end (which was very important).
And now that I am editing the film, I don’t
really know what I would have done without
it because every time I go into a scene, the
first thing I do is look at all the storyboards
to get a feeling for what Joe wants out of
the scene.
And knowing that, having that backbone, that
structure, allows me to kind of branch off
of it and to build off of it and to be more
creative because I can allocate more of my
mind and my time to the little details as
opposed to the backbone structure.
Cinematographer, Daniel Waghorne: I think
the storyboards are one of the most important
parts of making sure this film got made on
time.
I mean we shot 90 pages in 13 days, which
was kind of insane and I just remember the
first time that we were presented with storyboards,
I looked at this and said “This is going
to make my job a million times easier.”
The movie was basically already made and all
we had to do was just get in there and actually
shoot it and even though we did change up
a few things here or there, at least we still
had the foundation of everything already built.
So I was able to see exactly what Joe wanted
to make and that made everybody’s life a
hundred times easier.